un match pour croire à la montée le
voisin fc recevait laisse bûcher l'oise
ce dimanche 23 janvier les bisimwa ultra
dominateur sur la première période pense
ouvrir le score sur cette action mais le
but est refusé pour un hors jeu peu
évident un second but sera également
invalidé quelques minutes plus tard
après 45 minutes les deux prétendants
aux premières places letra lise 0 à 0
ils sont trois mi-temps que je maîtrise
pourtant déjà reparti relation prend 4
000 c'est flatteur pour nous parce que
son temps qu'à 0 5 0
c'est logique alors la première mi temps
on a on a fait une très bonne première
mi temps avec pas mal d'occasions on a
beaucoup garder le ballon
on leur a fait très très mal du coup il
était beaucoup retard ils ont fait
beaucoup de fois mon retour des
vestiaires même scénario voisins le
bretonneux poussé arrive finalement à
trouver le chemin des filets
cette fois ci le but est bien accorder
les joueurs locaux réussissent à tenir
ce score jusqu'à la fin 1 0 score final
on a réattaqué fort on met ce but au
bout de au bout d'un quart d'heure à peu
près après plusieurs buts refusés donc
un but qui nous fait du bien et on a
maîtrisé dans l'ensemble ça on a fait un
bon match dans les attitudes dans les
duels et puis on a réussi à garder score
surtout on à
lui reparti sur le dessous le après
juste après ce but la 60e minute je
crois il ya deux ans pour finir le match
on a des occasions de marquer pour
égaliser mais
justin logique au classement bûcher
l'oise est désormais 5e voisins le
bretonneux et 2e et reste au contact du
chéné leader de la division prochaine
journée le dimanche 30 janvier